key performance indicators you you might
you look at articles that tells you oh
the top five things that you should
measure on your website if you are in
such and such uh industry
the thing is key performance indicators
are are unique to your business yes of
course you can look at some guidelines
but here in this lesson we're gonna
we're gonna look at a way to
really align
what you measure
and what you identify as being a key
performance indicator so there's there's
meaning in those words key performances
getters means those are the essential
things that tells you that you are
driving you are going into the right
direction from a business standpoint a
couple of learning objectives um what
distinguish what is a kpi from a metric
uh of course depending on the context
what might be a metric in some context
might become a kpi in other contexts
we're going to make the distinction
between those um we're gonna
we're gonna identify what are the
attributes of a good kpi
and we're gonna
identify kpis that are really meaningful
for for your organization not not just a
magic list and and uh
you know over time i've realized that
there's simply no magic in what we're
doing
how many kpis do i need
and i like to
there's again there's no uh recipe magic
or whatever but we can learn and that's
uh what's
that's one of the aspect that i like
very much in our industry in our
discipline is that we should and we can
learn
from other disciplines so there's the
the five plus or or minus two rule of
thumb
how many bullet points should you have
on the powerpoint slide five plus or
minus two how many items should you have
in a menu
on a website five plus or minus two and
there was you know there was some
studies done by
a miller a guy named miller in in 1956
a psychologist who who looked at the
ability of the human brain to remember
elements or chunks of information and
what he found is that
most humans were able to understand five
plus or minus two elements so that's in
a way that's where it comes from
but if we apply that in the context of
how many kpis we need
we can we can use the same idea we can
use something to start with at least
with nuts
probably 20 kpis i can tell you it's
probably too much uh two kpis
maybe it's not enough to provide context
of your organization so five plus or
minus minus two uh is a good starting
point and and conversely you know while
we're talking about that
how many different analysis can a good
analyst do concurrently so you have some
analysis that are
more complex and will require more time
and you have other stuff that are easier
to do
use the five plus or minus two rule of
thumb if you are a junior analyst maybe
there's only three things that you can
do at the same time concurrently three
different analyst analysis that you can
do if you are much more experienced
maybe you can go up to seven
and there are some of them are going to
be uh at different stages of the lean
six sigma approach and you're gonna be
able to manage all of those so the the
rule of as a conclusion on that topic
the rule of five plus or minus two is
something that you can leverage with
your manager and and say you know i
didn't come up with that there's some
studies from a psychologist that has
been proven in the field and
my capacity my ability to be effective
in my work is to
work on
five plus or minus two things at the
same time
and start from there so leverage the
other expertise from other disciplines
in what you do
hey want to become an expert in digital
marketing then subscribe to the simply
learn channel and click here to watch
more such videos turn it up and get
certified in digital marketing click
here